field
results
[Music]
New ministers sworn in only 14 days
after Dina voluarte took over the
presidency
Former Defense Minister Alberto otarola
will now lead the cabinet in a country
immersed in political and social
turmoila it is time to recover peace and
give stability and governability to the
country gracias
on Wednesday tensions seemed to cool off
around the country a day after a
majority of legislators voted for
Boulevard to bring elections forward two
years by April 2024.
83 of peruvians demanded new general
elections
oterala's cabinet will now wait for a
vote of confidence in Congress some
political opponents say they must give
the government a chance instead tensions
rose on the Diplomatic front former
president Pedro Castillo's wife and
children were granted Asylum and flown
off to Mexico on Wednesday Peru
responded by expelling Mexico's
Ambassador
Mexico's president a friend of Castillo
defended his country's right to Grand
Asylum and announced Peru's government's
handling of the situation
the Peruvian government is highly
questioned as a whole for its actions
especially for opting for repression the
new prime minister said Lopez obrador's
statements are unfortunate and
unacceptable interference
we will not allow any person outside the
government of Peru to interfere
incessantly with the government of Peru
for now Peru's government is focused on
trying to quell tensions and seek to
restore order but the country is deeply
divided and remains under a state of
emergency